After days of negotiation,
for the very first time,
my parents allowed me
to step out unescorted
for a movie with my friends.
I was 14 and beyond excited
with this new freedom I had.
With a big smile on my face,
I ended up at the back of the theater.
And just ten steps from my seat,
I felt these heavy hands
grab both my breasts.
And before I knew it,
these hands disappeared.
I screamed and ran outside.
And I still remember
those dirty handprints
on my white, crisp cotton shirt,
announcing to the world
what had just happened.
I returned home devastated,
kept the lights on all through the night
and the outdoors terrified me.
I didn't want to go out at all.
It is not news that women
face rampant violence inside homes as well
across the world.
So if it's unsafe outside and inside,
where do we go?
Women in India
are over 600 million strong.
That's a lot of people.
But this is what my country looks like.
The outdoors.
You can count the number
of women in these pictures.
And there aren't any, or just one or two.
And this is by the day.
But this number
significantly drops at night.
You don't see many women
walking alone at night
because they're simply not safe.
400,000, that's 45 women every hour,
face varying degrees of violence,
ranging from domestic violence
to rape in India.
A 13-year-old girl and her mother
were gang-raped on a highway
just 45 minutes
from where my parents live.
When I heard this,
I just recalled the same incident
that happened to me.
I was devastated.
I found myself
in the same hysterical state
I was outside of that theater.
For everybody around me, life moved on.
We are hardwired to think
that this is just how the world is.
Instead of asking the fundamental question
of how wrong this is.
I'm here and I'm fighting
for safer spaces for women
by increasing their mobility,
by movement of the body and mind
to take control over their lives.
So how I did that.
I wanted to prove to the world
that I can face my demons.
And not just for one,
but 230 continuous days.
So I decided to walk
across the length of India
from the very south to the north,
a distance of 2,300 miles.
(Applause)
2,300 miles. How much is that?
If you started from LA,
you would reach New York.
If you started from Stockholm,
you would reach Cairo.
That's the distance that I walked.
And mile after mile, as I walked,
it became very apparent
that women's lack of mobility
hinders their freedom to earn an income
and exert any form of independence.
On my long walk,
I wanted to understand what made India
one of the most
unsafe countries in the world.
I was determined to meet the women
who are facing challenges
around their safety.
And above all, I wanted to understand
if the situation is beyond repair.
So I walked through 170 cities,
small towns and villages,
and I met over 85,000 women,
in small huddles to, like, large crowds.
This is a workshop.
This is with women of an organization
in small huddles inside their homes.
And that's when I realized
that mobility plays a very, very big role
in their freedom to pursue
anything outside of their homes.
When I was walking across the country,
in my conversations with these women,
I was talking to them
about different topics.
And this ranged
from being financially independent
to taking defensive positions
in times of physical assault.
This is an activity we did where we want
to anchor ourselves and find our ground,
and if somebody comes, you push.
Or just feel stronger.
What it feels in your body to be stronger.
And most of the times our discussions
were around finding your voice.
(Video) (Speaking Hindi)
(Together) Aaah!
I wanted women to move with their bodies
and to shift their minds.
The media amplified our cause
and reported with new energy
on a demand for a safer country for women.
On my long walk, I met so many people.
And most of the times,
I noticed that marriage in India
is treated a little differently
from the rest of the world.
You see, marriage means
a woman becomes the property
of her husband and his family.
And not being able to step outside
to pursue an education, a job,
or create a community of her own,
that's lack of mobility,
both social and physical,
that is what reflects the state
of gender inequality in our society.
On my long walk, I bore witness
to chilling, violent,
incomprehensible human behavior.
But at the same time, I met brave women,
survivors of atrocious crimes
who lit my path with their
unbelievable strength to carry on.
And then something miraculous happened.
I met this woman named Jai Bharathi.
On her motorcycle, she arrived
in the same village I was in,
and she was there at a training camp,
teaching other women how to ride scooters.
I had never seen
anything like this before.
She donned the narrative
of being fierce, the odd one out,
smashing patriarchy every single time
she rode her motorcycle.
She was an inspiration
for all women, young and old.
And at the training camp,
I saw how revving a motorbike
and holding a steering wheel
didn’t [justt] give these women
the ability to drive
but that much needed control
over their lives.
And I knew instantly
that having women take charge
and create change for themselves
is the only way
to transform our broken systems.
It got me thinking: What if we could
get communities of women moving,
actually physically moving
away from the house?
That would open a window
where they could move psychologically,
where they could understand or realize
that she could step out of bad situations
and have the ability to do it.
This way we would have
more women feel safe and confident.
So Jai Bharathi and I, we both decided
that we are going to join forces
and create a movement
exclusively for women,
focused on mobility.
We have set up a system where a woman
can train to drive for themselves
or for Ubers, taxis,
or just become delivery agents
for Amazon and other big companies
or local businesses.
That's money in the bank.
And the freedom
and the psychological, you know --
know that I can step outside of my home.
We are connecting these women drivers
on a national network
where they can reach out
to each other for support
and to share experiences.
And not just that.
She can actually ping
another driver in her vicinity
if she is feeling distressed,
if she's in danger,
or if she’s simply just waiting
for her next ride or pickup
and doesn't want to wait alone.
For us, receiving our first paycheck
might be very empowering.
But for 59-year-old Nagamani
that moment arrived when she
put her scooter on a center stand
and feeling physically strong,
and proving to the society
that she's beyond being just a sidekick.
We have trained 1,800 women
who are road ready.
(Applause)
And raring.
Road ready and raring to go.
And our decade-long mission is
to bring one million women into mobility
and be the largest network
of women drivers connected to each other.
By rethinking mobility for women,
giving them a safe transport
and safety outside of home,
it is our hope to transform our culture.
Apart from having a profound impact
on the Indian economy,
this is about something much bigger.
As you all know,
when we move, we can be seen.
The more women
see other women in public spaces,
the more safe, independent
and empowered each one of us will be.
So.
If we can learn how to walk,
certainly we can learn how to fly.
Thank you.
(Applause)